docteur génétique etes-vous pour ou
contre le vin je suis pour le 20 mai on
ne doit jamais de toute façon dépasser
trois quarts de litre par jour
on peut dire aussi qu'une nation
qualitative du vin intervient et les vin
frelaté un peu tourmenté par les uns et
les autres seront des vins beaucoup plus
nocifs
d'autre part vous êtes médecin sportif
donc vous devez avoir pour les sportifs
des normes encore plus sévère les
sportifs peuvent boire du vin même en
période de grandes compétitions et même
s'ils ont la classe internationale mais
du vin votre entité très restreinte
pendant les repas seulement d'ailleurs
aux jeux olympiques de londres les
français avaient manqué le vin et cet
incident avait joué sur leur état
d'esprit pendant un certain temps
cela répond à mener des contre
performances humaines n'ont pas de
compteur soir forme ans tout de même
mais des incidents psychologique
a tokyo les français au maine leur faim
avez vous l'impression qu'on boit moins
de 20 dans la région car j'ai
l'impression et panet notes prennent
acte d'abord le bonnes maisons de vins
seront plus en plus rares tous les
anciens bistrots où on était vraiment
recommandé pour le vin ont disparu
et puis de l'autre côté la jeunesse
emploi pro il se boit quand même un peu
moins de 20 que d'habitude
chez nous nous en ont dû ainsi les vins
d'appellation contrôlée beaujolais et
mâconnais mais des côtes du rhône quel
elvin kalaja prédilection de vos clients
c'est le beaujolais a lyon les clients
sont des connaisseurs d'abord parce
qu'ils habitent près du beaujolais et
ils ont l'occasion on avait souvent le
dimanche en voiture se s'y promener
c'est une région très agréable les
amateurs alors penche pour quel vin
qu'elle disputera l'an passé les
amateurs aiment le beau jeu des bleus
mâconnais vous avez l'impression tout de
même que vos clients sont connaisseurs
ah oui oui les mains il apparaît que les
rues d'alger qui avait regardé voyez la
goutte la bougie disons à y viennent pas
pour les cardabelles